ist die situation vor ort guten morgen
euch beiden die situation vor ort ist
die dass wir jetzt geschichte jetzt
ungefähr zwei kilometer luftlinie vom
explosionsort entfernt auf der anderen
rheinseite also links rein ich sozusagen
noch auf kölner stadtgebiet diese
explosion die soll die gab es so
ungefähr gegen 39
wir sind dann sofort los und max das ist
eben schon gesagt die umliegenden
straßen auch die autobahnen die zu
diesem park hin schüttet die sind schon
gesperrt so dass auch wir alle von
dieser autobahn runter mussten
man kann sagen dass zumindest alles was
dahin muss also werkfeuerwehr polizei
gut durchgekommen ist die rettungsgasse
wurde sofort hervorragend bildet das
habe ich selber mit musste dann eben
selber auch von der autobahn runter und
stehe jetzt wie gesagt hier ungefähr
zwei kilometer luftlinie entfernt vom
explosionsort ich drehe das ganze bild
mal etwas um wenn das funktioniert hier
ich kann euch mal ein mal zeigen wo wir
stehen und zwar ist das hier rechts von
mir die ehe leverkusener a1 brücke die
bereits gesperrt wurde wir sind ein
heruntergeleitet wurden und sehen dann
eben auf der anderen seite diese riesige
rauchwolke ich habe eben schon mit
anwohnern sprechen können die sagten wir
haben die explosionen in ihre unserem zu
hause mitbekommen und es war dann eben
offenbar so eine große druckwelle dass
türen zuschlagen und auch wieder
aufstehen also es scheint schon eine
extrem heftige explosion gewesen zu sein
dann sieht das da drüben der rauch
steigt immer noch auf und was etwas
verwirrend bis interessant ist dass
tatsächlich die menge an rauch die
darauf steigt immer wieder auch geringer
und dann wieder mehr wird das könnte
dafür stehen dass die feuerwehr bereits
in einem einsatz ist und dort eben schon
teile löschen konnte dieses explosions
herdes oder das eben weitere dieser
stoffe die dort gelagert und verbrannt
werden immer wieder in diesem jahr
brandquelle reingeraten dem erstmal
vielen dank dass du es überhaupt dahin
geschafft hast und uns läuft diese
bilder bringst kannst du uns noch
einsatz dazu sagen was genau ist das für
ein ort der da brennt was geschieht dort
genau das ist wie gesagt ein
entsorgungszentrum der firma currenta
sind das ganze chempark in leverkusen da
sind also die stiege stoffe teilweise
auch einfach eine müllverbrennungsanlage
die der dort eben die deutschen dafür
sorgt dass der müll leben eigentlich
kontrolliert verbrannt wird
man kann jetzt nicht genau sagen was
genau dort in brand geraten ist
es gibt erste meldungen darüber dass ist
eine tankanlage sein soll was vielleicht
auch für diesen dunklen sehr fast schon
schwarzen rauch sprechen würde
allerdings ist das alles noch
unbestätigt deswegen würde ich mich
damals mit solchen dingen auch bis auf
weiteres zurückhaltend was ist die grund
was jetzt die ursache dieses brandes ist
wie gesagt auf jeden fall lagern dort
chemie stoffe deswegen gibt es eben auch
die warnung an die anwohner auf beiden
seiten dieser anlage fenster und türen
geschlossen zu halten möglichst in den
eigenen vier wänden zu bleiben
ich konnte jetzt eben hier mit leuten
sprechen die sich das ganze sozusagen
erstmal aus der hexen er wie das dann
immer so ist anschauen wollten sie
tragen jetzt jedoch keine masken auch
die polizei geht hier abgesperrt hat ist
noch nicht mit masken ausgestattet
weil eben offenbaren dieser dieser
brandherd und auch der rauch erstmal
weiter auf der anderen rheinseite liegt
deswegen scheint man hier jetzt erstmal
geschützt zu sein wie sich das ganze
entwickelt muss man sehen
der wind der tat das ganze so ein
bisschen in richtung norden in
nördlichere stadtteile von daher wird es
vor allem dort eben am ende darauf
ankommen jetzt erstmal sicher im eigenen
heim zu bleiben und sich vor eventuellen
russ eventuell braucht er sich dort
nieder schlägt zu schützen
er hat in vielen dank schon mal für den
moment bleibt es ja vor uns mit für uns
immerhin in der nähe aber auch nicht zu
nah dran denn wir haben es ja gerade
schon gesagt es ist eine giftwolke oder
es kann eine giftwolke seien im aus
diesem chemiepark die polizei hat gerade
auch schon berichtet dass es wohl
mehrere verletzte geben soll und sobald
es da weitere informationen gibt finden
sie diese natürlich immer aktuell auf
bild.de
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren